اغلقت السلطات في ولايه كاليفورنيا بنك
وادي سيليكون الامريكي اكبر مقرض لشركات
الناشئه في مجال التكنولوجيا وعينت
المؤسسه الفيدراليه للتامين على الودائع
وصيا على البنك بعد اعلان افلاسه وتخطط
المؤسسه لسماح للعملاء بسحب ما يصل الى
200 وخمسين الف دولار على المدى القصير
وهو المبلغ الذي عاده ما تضمنه المؤسسه
وكان لدى البنك في نهايه 2022 اصول بقيمه
209 مليار دولار وودائع مقدارها نحو 174
مليار دولار واغلاق البنك لا يمثل اكبر
عمليه افلاس مصرفي منذ العام 2018 فحسب بل
ثاني اكبر افلاس ايضا لبنك بالتجزئه في
الولايات المتحده
المزيد مع مراسله الجزيره من واشنطن بيسان
مزيد من الايضاحات
نعم عبد السلام هذا البنك الذي كما ذكرت
يعد من اكبر البنوك التجاريه هنا في
الولايات المتحده
القائمه العشرين لهذه البنوك بعد
عده عوامل كما يقول الخبراء والمحللون
منها ما يتعلق برفع الاحتياط الفيدرالي
لاسعار الفائده
لمواجهه التضخم مما ادى الى ابطاء في
الاستثمارات في قطاع التكنولوجيا ايضا
النقص في راس المال الاستثماري في قطاع
التكنولوجيا مما قلل من الودائع وحتى ربما
صاحب ودائع ادى الى عده امور ساهمت في
انهيار هذا البنك خصوصا بعد اعلانه بيع
سندات ضمان بخساره الاسبوع الماضي مما
احدث حاله من الهلع لدى الموضعين ليهرعوا
بسحب ودائعهم وايضا سقوط وانخفاض اسهمه في
اسواق المال صباح الثلاثاء وهنا تدخلت
السلطات يوم الجمعه الان ما ننتظره هو انه
يوم الاثنين
سيفتح البنك فروع فروعه كي يتمكن الموضعين
الذين لديهم ودائع مؤمنه من ان يسحبوا
ودائعهم ولكن وفق الارقام ف 89 في المئه
من الودائع التي يبلغ مجموعها 175 مليار
دولار في هذا البنك غير مؤمنه الان هناك
ايضا مساعي لتدخل شركه تامين الودائع
الفيدراليه وهي وكاله فيدراليه لبيع ما
لدى هذا البنك من اصول لتسديد ما لدى
المودعين من اموال او حتى قيام بنك اخر
ربما بشرائه وحصول عمليه اندماج وانقاذ
ربما هذا البنك من مما حدث شكرا جزيلا
لكويت مراسله الجزيره من واشنطن على كل
هذه الايضاح